- That was unpleasant.
(upbeat music)
- I've enjoyed Lush.
I know it's very expensive but it's great.
- I'm into this because
it sounds like a bath bomb
for your little mouth, and I like that.
- I think this is just a ploy
to make brushing your teeth different.
- It's not broken, don't fix it.
- [Narrator] Bling toothie tabs.
- I'll tell you, it's glittery
as (bleep) and I like that.
- Press tablet between your teeth,
grab your wet toothbrush
and brush as usual
then rinse clean, okay.
- What do we do?
- Crunch it, oh oh!
- Oh!
- Oh, it tastes worse.
- Uh, it tastes like a vitamin C tablet.
- Yeah it does.
- This is like asking
for your dog or your baby
to just be like a click
click (mimicking gargling).
Now my insides are glittery
and my poop looks like gold.
- Boom, toothie tabs.
- It's charcoal?
- It's charcoal and chili.
- Charcoal's really good for you though.
- It smells fantastic.
I bet it tastes like (bleep).
- Oh, it's so bad.
- Oh.
(screaming)
- Oh, you look scary AF.
- Thank you.
- Why am I doing this,
why am I doing this?
- This is some witches' brew.
- My spit is still coming out black.
- That was terrible and then
I turned and I looked at you
and it got even more terrible.
- [Narrator] Ultrablast.
- Tooth powder, oh okay.
- And this has wasabi.
- It sounds kinda good
to me, I gotta be real.
- Oh yeah, it smells like toothpaste.
- I love the toothpaste
flavored toothpaste.
- Okay.
- Alright.
- This is not bad.
- I don't taste any wasabi in this Steven.
- What?
- Oh yeah, I love this.
- I'm getting back in there.
- This one I feel the most fresh.
- [Narrator] Tooth fairy tooth powder.
- Dab your damp toothbrush into the pot
to apply some powder and get brushing.
- Wow, I feel like this is
something I purchased at Claire's
- It kinda smells like lotion
that you would get when
you're 13, with shimmer in it.
- Yes.
- Oh my God.
- Ew, tastes like fun dip.
- This is my favorite one.
- Why, something in the mouth?
- Yeah.
- You could probably use
this as a highlighter, wait
- If you're going to prom.
- How's it look?
- It's so shimmery.
- There's a time of the day for candy,
there's a time of the day for toothpaste.
It's not the same time.
(bell ringing)
- They are very like health
and morally conscious brand,
which is good and I like that.
The flavors just were too terrible.
- Bad.
- Lush didn't need to go
so crazy with the flavors.
- But I like the thought.
I like the experimental nature of it.
- Oh this was made by Max.
- Oh, thanks Max.
- Hi Max.
- I wanna work at Lush
just so I have a sticker
with my face on it.
- Make me make you one.
- Oh.